[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and welcome
to episode number 158
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I am Mark Mandel, and I'm here
with my colleague, Melanie
Warrick.
Hello, Melanie.
MELANIE WARRICK: Hello, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: I am
back from vacation.
MELANIE WARRICK: Welcome back.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you very much.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Do you feel rested?
MARK MANDEL: I feel rested.
Thank you for taking care
of things while I was gone.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yes, well somebody
had to keep it insane--
keep it insane.
Somebody had to
keep it straight.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, somebody's
got to keep the lights on,
I understand.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Something like that.
But yeah, we survived.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
What are we doing this week?
MELANIE WARRICK: That's
a great question.
What are we doing this week?
MARK MANDEL: This
week, we're talking
to VP of engineering,
Melody Meckfessel, which
is a great interview,
really looking forward
to getting stuck into that.
And then after that we have
our question of the week,
if I want to configure
third-party notifications
such as Slack or GitHub into
my Cloud Build configurations,
how can I do that?
MELANIE WARRICK: That's
a great question, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: I may
even have an answer.
MELANIE WARRICK: Where did
that question come from?
OK, so cool things of the week.
Let's go ahead and get started
with that, which we've already
said that you're
back, but I think one
of the big things
for us this week
and specifically at the
beginning of this week,
we had two million downloads.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
I know, crazy.
Wow.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you listeners.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you
listeners, thank you, everyone.
Thanks to you Melanie,
thanks to Francesc.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK: You've
got to get that in there
because you know he's
going to call you out.
MARK MANDEL: I know
he's listening.
MELANIE WARRICK: If he
doesn't hear that, he's got--
anyways, yes, thank
you, Francesc.
But also yes, good job, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's been a
little more than three years,
and the two million came
in a little bit more
than nine months after the first
million took about 28 months.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: As long as
things go up and to the right,
everything's fine.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
clearly people like this.
MARK MANDEL: I hope so.
MELANIE WARRICK: Supposedly.
Maybe not.
No, so yes, thank you.
Thank you, listeners.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks, everyone.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
know last time we
didn't mention it on the
podcast itself, but yay podcast!
MARK MANDEL: It's been
a good run, good run.
MELANIE WARRICK: Good guest.
OK, another cool thing of the
week that we wanted to mention
is that our glorious leader--
[TRUMPET PLAYING]
--as Holden might say, is,
Craig Wilson from the team,
he has been sharing out this
Google Cloud developers cheat
sheet, and he has
created a GitHub repo now
that you can use to access it.
He's got a number
of different things
on there that you can
use to play around with.
But it's a nice cheat sheet
that gives you just these
four-word--
MARK MANDEL: Definitions.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Definitions, yeah.
Four words or less.
So--
MARK MANDEL: It's not
a strict four-word.
MELANIE WARRICK:
If you want to know
about GCP cloud or Firebase or
Apigee, any of these things,
if you have questions
and you don't want
to have to spend a lot of
time reading up on them,
you can just take
a look at the sheet
and it will give
you a quick summary.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, because
there's a lot of things now.
MELANIE WARRICK: There is.
MARK MANDEL: There's a lot.
MELANIE WARRICK:
All right, Mark,
you got something else for us?
MARK MANDEL: I got
some fun stuff.
So on the open-source
gaming front, Agones,
the open-source Kubernetes-based
game server scaling and hosting
solution--
MELANIE WARRICK:
That you created.
MARK MANDEL: --yeah, that I
started along with some other
people--
we're in 0.6.0 right now.
So we just had a
release on that.
Every six weeks that's
happening, but yeah,
that's going along at
quite the ready clip.
And along those veins
as well, Open Match,
the open source
matchmaking platform
has gone 0.2.0
release candidate,
and there's a bunch of new
functionality in there as well.
They're refactoring a whole
bunch of things in there,
and it's, yeah, it's
turning into a really nice
little platform.
MELANIE WARRICK: Woo hoo.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's pretty sweet.
MELANIE WARRICK: And another
cool thing we want to mention
is some of the cool
things announced over
at the Firebase Summit.
There's a good blog
post that covers that.
Apparently Firebase is being
used by over 1.5 million apps.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
they've got a bunch
of new features, actually,
a whole slew of stuff
that I actually didn't
realize that was in here.
MELANIE WARRICK:
One in particular
you were very excited.
MARK MANDEL: One in particular
I got very excited about.
So iOS support for
Test Lab has gone GA,
which I am very excited about.
So Firebase Test
Lab is a platform
for testing your mobile apps
in real live environment,
and now you can do it both
on Android and on iOS, which
makes me very, very happy.
MELANIE WARRICK: Woo hoo.
MARK MANDEL: There's
a lot of cool stuff
in here from performance
monitoring, enhancements, crash
analytics, being
integrated with PagerDuty,
doing more stuff with BigQuery
and Data Studio, lots and lots
and lots of cool things.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And you can read
all about that on the blog
post, that we will include
a link in the show notes.
MARK MANDEL: We will indeed.
MELANIE WARRICK:
All right, Mark,
I think that's it
for our cool things
of the week for this week,
so let's go talk to Melody.
MARK MANDEL: So I am
definitely very, very
excited to have Melody
Meckfessel, VP of engineering
here at Cloud joining us
yet again on the podcast.
How you doing, Melody?
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
I'm doing well.
Thanks for having me.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you so
much for joining us today.
Looking forward to
talking to you again.
In case people didn't
go back and listen
to the episodes we
did around Next,
can you tell us a little about
who you are and what you do,
what's your background?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: I got
into computer science right
after college, building systems
at a startup and enterprise
software.
I actually have my
Google-versary this week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Mazel tov.
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
I know, I know.
MELANIE WARRICK: Congrats.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: And
several years ago I
started working on how to
make developers at Google
more productive.
Where were we wasting time,
how do we make them happy?
And it's really been
this awesome journey
of learning about
how Google has made
one of the most productive and
highest velocity engineering
teams in the world,
and how do we
bring that out to other
communities outside of Google.
So teams doing
open-source development,
teams interacting with
Android and Chrome,
and then also
developers and operators
using Google's Cloud Platform.
So it's this really
awesome blend
of sharing what we've
learned internally,
collaborating with our partners
to be providing the best
services in the ecosystem,
and then contributing
to open-source products
that are already
out there that developers
love and care about
or open sourcing things that we
feel like the community would
benefit from.
So what really motivates and
inspires me is how does my team
and how does Google help
influence and improve
how software engineering
happens in the world?
And it really is about the
people, the developers,
all different
backgrounds, operators,
all different backgrounds,
getting the benefit out
of the work that we've done.
MELANIE WARRICK: What are some
of the key successes for you
for this year that you've seen
in terms of helping developers?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: So this
was-- you mentioned Next.
This was kind of our
debut year, a little bit.
We launched Cloud
Source Repositories
at sort of the next level,
bringing code search,
and Cloud Build integration with
some great open-source partner
work, and then have made
some significant improvements
in Stackdriver, which
provides monitoring
solutions for operators.
We launched Instant
Response and Management.
So that's used by Google
SREs as well as operators
using Google's Cloud Platform.
So it really is about
this end to end experience
for what people call
DevOps and the way
that we think about
DevOps at Google
as automation
around the developer
workflow and the culture.
So the practices and
the ways in which
the humans are interacting.
That was a big thing
for us this year.
I'm pretty excited about it.
And when I look at it, it's
open source, great partner
integration, working
with folks like GitLab
and integrating with GitHub, and
then putting some products out
to the marketplace, which
has been a lot of fun.
MARK MANDEL: Just a couple
of products, not a lot.
[LAUGHTER]
You mentioned something
interesting there, too,
when you were talking about
the incident response used
both by external
people, like people
who develop on Google
Cloud, as well as SREs.
Is that a pattern
that we're looking
to keep going with, where stuff
is both internal and external,
or bringing stuff
internal to external?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: It is.
We've sort of optimized
internal to our environment.
You know, you think
about Borg, and you
think about us taking
our storage systems out
into the market with Cloud
Spanner, right-- great launch
this year-- but I
think there's magic
that can happen when both
the internal Google teams
and external teams are
using the same products
and learning from each other.
We're hearing input
from our customer teams
that we're then bringing back
to help us innovate internally.
And that's just such a
magical bi-directional sort
of learning that can happen
between these communities.
And my goal is to have that
happen as much as we possibly
can, where we
break down walls so
that developers and operators
can learn from each other.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Where do you see this going in
terms of trends, what you've
seen so far, what do you
think that's going to look
like the next year and beyond?
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
So probably heard
about this thing, Kubernetes.
MARK MANDEL: No.
I don't know anything
about Kubernetes.
MELANIE WARRICK: Mark
never talks about that.
[LAUGHTER]
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
Well, you know,
amazing engagement
with the community,
and just looking at the
data of enterprise customers
experimenting with
Kubernetes and bringing it
into their on-prem environment.
So our goal in DevOps is to
have an amazing experience
for containers on GCP.
This is a theme that
we committed to.
You look at our launches
around vulnerability scanning,
around the support
in Stackdriver.
Across the board we
want the best experience
for using containers
to be on GCP, again,
in a way that's open and builds
on all the great momentum
that's happening
in the community.
So that's a trend
that I don't think
we could have predicted how
quickly teams would be adopting
use of containers
in their business
and how they write applications
and how they modernize.
So that's a trend that I see
just up and to the right--
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: --faster than
we can predict in many ways.
And when enterprises
are looking to modernize
their applications, there's
some ridiculous statistic,
very high, meaning in
the 80%, that they're
looking to use containers
for modernizing on-prem
and then as they
come to the cloud.
So that's a trend we're
fully committed to.
It shouldn't be surprising.
But I think the usage
in terms of adoption
is happening much faster
than we thought it would.
So we're paying
attention to that.
We're looking at adoption, we're
looking at customer feedback.
The other trend that I
would highlight would be Go.
The Go community is thriving.
The predictions of usage
increase, the feedback
around respect and
inclusion in the community
is really inspiring to
me and just awesome.
And so that, in terms
of Google's contribution
and participation
to that community,
really committed to
continuing to make
Go a great language that
solves a variety of problems
and works great on GCP.
The third pattern
that I would highlight
would be we started this
experiment within Google
to learn about
developer productivity.
An interesting
part about this is
that it has both qualitative
and quantitative.
So we measure
everything at Google,
right, we're always trying
to learn from the data.
But there's also a
qualitative aspect
of this, of how happy are the
humans, how satisfied are they?
And, you know, engineers are
tough to make happy, right?
[LAUGHTER]
The general healthy skepticism
and keep raising the bar.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Spaces and tabs.
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
So one of the things
that we're really
excited about is
bringing some of those
insights into productivity
out into the market.
And when I talk to
our partners, we're
all sort of thinking about
as millions of developers
come to the cloud, how do we
help have them be productive
and maybe a little bit happy
and enabled to create and take
their ideas to reality in a
way that's a good experience?
So that's a trend that I see
us being very committed to
in terms of helping developers
and operators on the platform.
MARK MANDEL: You were talking
a little bit about Kubernetes
and running anywhere.
I'd love to hear your
take on where you
think hybrid cloud is going.
Is that something
you think is going
to expand more or contract?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Yes.
So again, we look at
the research data,
we're pretty committed to
learning from our customers.
Again, in the
mid-80%, enterprise
customers are looking
to hybrid cloud.
They're committing to solutions
that support hybrid cloud.
Amazing announcement
with GKE On-Prem,
right, great feedback
around that alpha launch
that's coming in from
a DevOp standpoint,
help the developers and
operators be productive
whether they're on-prem
or on the cloud.
And we know that
customers are going
to be making different
decisions around their journey
to the cloud, so we want
to support them in that
and empower them in that.
I think yes and yes,
it will continue
to be a key priority
for GCP and for making
developers and operators happy.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
you'd mentioned before--
I know we talked already a
little bit about Kubernetes--
what are some of the
other open-source projects
that you're particularly
excited about,
that you may have a bias about,
that are specifically ones
that you enjoy and inspired by?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: So I
will highlight a pattern
that I'm seeing, which is--
MELANIE WARRICK: I like that.
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
--not anything specific,
but I think if you
look at the pattern,
you can see a bunch of really
cool innovation happening.
So the CI/CD,
Continuous Integration
and Continuous Delivery
space, is really fragmented.
And so what we're
seeing is either
around Kubernetes or around
aspects of what developers are
trying to solve these
problems, there's
these open source-tools
that are coming up
that are very specific
to particular things
that developers need to do.
So an example of that would be
Skaffold, which we talked about
at Tokyo Next.
It's focused on
how do we make it
really easy to run Kubernetes
on your local environment.
And we know that developers
want to be portable.
They want to develop anywhere.
So you can see these
bits where, hey, there's
this pain in my workflow.
I'm going to develop something
that is open source first,
that can get contributions
from the community.
Same thing with Minikube,
which was something
we released a while
ago, but I think
that part of the
ecosystem is incredibly
creative and inspiring in that
the community is looking for--
like, solve specific
problems that's
grounded in pain that
developers are feeling today.
And so I'm sure there's big
massive open-source projects
that we don't even know
about that are on their way,
but I think I'm sort of inspired
by some of the smaller things
that I'm seeing that are gaining
traction that are helping
developers get their job done.
MELANIE WARRICK: I like that.
MARK MANDEL: That's very cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
Another question, actually,
that's come to my mind.
Where did you start out?
[LAUGHTER]
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Well,
I guess I should say
I grew up in rural California.
So there were
literally eight kids
in my elementary school class.
Math and science and computer
science were not top of mind.
But I feel super grateful
that I had some teachers that
saw that I was really
interested in math and science
and through up into
college, really
supported me in seeking out
how to learn about this area.
Got to college, wanted to learn
more about computer science,
at the college I went to
wasn't a great community,
so I studied some other things.
I studied about
biology and history.
And then was
dabbling on the side
and taking classes
and learning more.
And started my
career at a startup
where I was having to do
pretty much everything,
learn the front end,
the back end, you know,
full stack developer.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Before,
that was just a job.
That was what you did.
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
That was what I did.
And then I started working
building enterprise software
for banks and energy
companies and saw
what happened with the bubble
and bust in Silicon Valley,
and multiple iterations of that.
So it's definitely
been quite a journey
of seeing how the
industry has evolved,
seeing the patterns of
sort of ebb and flow
of grounding in the business and
grounding in what users need,
and also seeing the
tests that have happen.
There's a big cultural
test, I think,
going on right now in the valley
around inclusion and diversity.
I'm really committed
to, in the work
that we're doing
in DevOps, creating
the most inclusive and
respectful experience
for developers and operators.
So if you think about great
interactions in code review.
MELANIE WARRICK: And I'll
deviate for a second.
Are there any specific
things that you recommend
for those who want to be
more inclusive in regards
to code reviews and other
types of just bringing people
into these type of things,
bringing into tech?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: All-- again,
if we come back to the data,
all the data shows Google
and many other tech companies
are building products for
a diverse set of users.
However, when you look
at the humans that
are actually building
those products,
it's not a diverse team.
So we miss things.
We miss-- and you can look in
examples of just missing it.
And we need to do a better job.
We need to be explicit
and thoughtful
about the communities and
the users that we're serving.
And I strongly believe that
diversity of perspectives
will lead to better products
for the diverse set of users
that we're trying to help.
And I think-- so what people
can bring, bring openness.
Bring curiosity.
Bring questions.
Be respectful and open to
different perspectives.
Listen, we all have a part
to play in every interaction.
MELANIE WARRICK:
I mean, here you
have this wonderful robust
extensive experience
in the space in
general that you're
able to bring to how
you view, how you lead.
What are some of the
key skills that you
feel like you've
been able to gain
over the last several
years in particular
that's helped you really
lead and transition more
as a leader and
not as much as a--
like, you're
building, but you're
leading others to build now.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Yeah.
I have had some awesome
allies and mentors
that I've gone to
for help, that really
helped me check my own
stories that I would tell.
I know I've mentioned
this to you before.
I'm a big fan of Brené Brown.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, you have.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: And you know,
I'm going to butcher the quote,
but she has something
like, sometimes
the most courageous thing
we can do is just show up.
And I think showing
up as who you are
is something that I have
learned over the years
in tech, being the only woman
in the room many, many times,
to show up in how I want
to model leadership.
And that comes back
to caring and kindness
for the people around
me and inspiring
toward these big,
audacious goals
that we have in the world.
I really believe that we work
really hard on these goals.
We spend a lot of time
together, and the experience
of people working together,
feeling cared for,
feeling respected, feeling like
their perspective is valued,
is such an important
part of doing good work.
And when people don't
feel like that it's
going to be more
difficult to accomplish
those big, audacious goals.
So for me the
transition in leadership
was embracing
showing up as myself
and coming from a place
of caring and kindness
for the people around me and
really showing that to people.
Along with the technical
debates and the details
and all that great stuff.
We can have both.
MARK MANDEL: And to bring
that full circle as well,
I'm guessing that feeds back
into as you look to developers
or people who use
our products, how
to make them happier as well.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Yeah.
So user experience
research, right?
Listening to them, listening
to their perspectives.
Hearing what's working for them,
what's not working for them.
Coming from a place of
empathy, of how to help them.
I really believe in the more
we see the pain in the products
that we're developing,
the more focus we're
going to have to solving those
problems, which, to come back
to your point about instant
response and management,
we need to make sure that
we're addressing the pain
points for both our
internal communities
and our external
communities, and that
keeps us super focused on
making that the best experience
that we can.
MELANIE WARRICK:
What do you like
to hack on when you
have your own downtime?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: I don't
know that I'm getting
a lot of downtime these days.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Probably not lately.
[LAUGHTER]
MELODY MECKFESSEL: But
what do I do when I
have a block of deep work time?
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: It is
about writing down and then
getting at the whiteboard
around the things
that we need to be thinking
about a year or two years
from now.
So really pushing ourselves
on the bleeding edge of what
the experience could be.
I think there's just a lot
of room for improvement
in how developers
write software,
and how much toil there is,
and there's some things a year
or two out around how to
have the experiences be
more natural, more
insightful, more intuitive,
include more automation,
that I want us to work on so.
When I have downtime
I write and whiteboard
and start to put
the ideas out there
so that we can iterate on them.
MELANIE WARRICK: And strategize.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know you
were talking about Brené Brown
in particular as a resource,
as somebody who's inspired,
but when you're thinking about
what's next and where things
are going, what are some
resources and people and tools
that you turn to help
you get some ideas?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: I turn to
research and internal data
and external data.
So there's an
organization called
DORA, which is the DevOps
research group, led
by an awesome team, Nicole
and Jez and Gene and Soo,
they have been studying
DevOps practices
and what makes DevOps teams
perform well for a long time.
They just released a
report, so that's something
that Google helped sponsor
and are a big believer in,
in terms of understanding
the practices.
So I look to that.
One of the themes that came
up in the latest report
was security, and this
idea of shifting left.
Like how can you move
security closer to code,
than you're finding a security
issue out in production?
So we're really listening to
that external research as a way
to sort of think about how
we embed security practices
and policies and automation
closer to the code,
much farther away
from the end user
impact, just as an example.
So I look to research.
I look to research internally.
We have a great research
organization team here
that meets with customers, that
works with external customer
survey groups, and we
do our own surveys.
So I'm really looking
to hear from people
and understand that data as I'm
processing what's next for us.
MARK MANDEL: Given that
you're doing all that research
and you mentioned security, what
are the challenges that you're
actually seeing people are
having out in the wild?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Well, one
is that the toil is so high.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: So it's
like how do I know what to use
and how do I create the glue
to keep it all together?
Lot of pain around that.
Security is really top of mind.
So if you think about the
patterns of open source usage,
again, up and to the
right, enterprise companies
are adopting open source,
everyone's using it,
the rate of contributions
is increasing.
Do we know what our
dependencies are to open source?
We don't have a lot of
transparency into that.
MELANIE WARRICK: We don't.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: So
there's risk, right?
And that's a problem Google will
help solve in the community.
So transparency is a big one.
We don't know what we're
dependent on in the stack.
Security, transparency,
I think moving quickly.
So I will say, coming
back to productivity,
when I talk to customers,
the productivity in some
of their organizations is low,
and when you do some debugging,
it could be because the
teams don't trust each other,
like there's resistance
to releasing software.
So they have one
release a quarter,
versus 10 releases a day.
So you sort of dig into how do
we help teams learn and build
trust?
But yeah, I would say security,
transparency, productivity,
continuing our
focus on automation.
People are struggling with that.
And then I think Google
can help play a role
and embrace standards
that are starting
to evolve in the different
spaces that we're working.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Particularly the fact
that you'd mentioned
about people struggling
with the automation piece,
it's interesting to watch,
because I know I've seen
us moving in these fits
and starts in some
ways of like, we
want to automate as
much as possible,
but yet we also recognize
there's only so much that can
at certain times be automated.
And it's continually evolving.
But it's fascinating, and
it's fun to watch, too,
in a lot of ways.
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
Another point around
that is that more so
than any other time,
60% plus of developers
feel like they have
a choice in their tool set.
So the fastest way to
make a developer unhappy
is to waste their time.
They're going to pick the thing
that makes them productive,
like they're empowered.
So if you look at
automation, they
want the thing that's going
to help them remove that toil.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
I mean, especially when you're
doing a thing with machine
learning and trying to model,
the last thing you want to do
is spend most of your time just
trying to set up your system.
You want to just get to
[INAUDIBLE] if anything,
and then also getting the
data and cleaning the data.
That's where a large part of
your time will get sucked into,
and the more you can
actually automate that,
the faster you can
get to a solution.
Off of that note, I might as
well go for this question,
since we are the "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast,"
are there any cloud
products that particularly
are your favorites?
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
Do-- I don't know.
MARK MANDEL: Do you
have a favorite child?
[LAUGHTER]
MELODY MECKFESSEL: No, I think--
MELANIE WARRICK: Since you
have an emphasis on DevOps,
maybe there is a favorite there.
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
I would say I'm
pretty excited about
the contributions
that we're making in
the Cloud Build space.
It really is a combination
of first-party solutions
that automate and work
well on the platform,
it's great integration
with our partners,
there's open-source
components of it,
you know, Bazel, we open
sourced Google's build system,
has a part to play in that.
And I think on the op side,
I'm super inspired by the work
that the team has done
within Stackdriver
to bring SRE tools
and practices out
into the external community.
I spoke at our Cloud
SRE Summit last week
and there's just
so much excitement
about bringing the best
practices, the insights,
helping people get the insights
so they don't have to go down
the rabbit hole of debugging
things or struggling,
which really gets to
the better business
outcome for those teams, right?
Minimize the user impact,
that's the end game.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
So I'm super excited.
I mean, we have a
ton more work to do.
We're really excited about
the features we're developing.
And I think 2019 is going
to be an exciting year.
MELANIE WARRICK: If you
weren't doing what you're doing
right now, what would you do?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: I don't know.
That's a great question.
I am coaching elementary
school girls' volleyball team,
and I have to say
it is such a joy.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: So--
MELANIE WARRICK: Clearly
different shift in mind?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Teaching,
some sort of teaching thing,
working with people.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Making things easier.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: We talked
about this to a degree before,
but what advice would
you give to those
who are growing their career
in engineering, especially
in the DevOps space?
Is there any advice in
particular you'd give to them?
Because I know
it's different now,
still, there's
similar challenges
of getting into the space.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: So
there's a couple points
that I would highlight.
Really try and find your
passion in the space.
You know, there's this whole
idea of purpose and passion.
When I talk with engineers that
are new to the space or new
in the field, find
something that, really, they
can connect with.
And I think from my own
lessons learned in my career
when I wasn't connected to
the work in some way, inspired
by it, things didn't really go
as well as I would have liked.
MARK MANDEL: That's fair.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK: I can
very much relate to that.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: The
second thing I would say
is find your people.
Find the people that
are going to support you
and challenge you within
your team and outside
of your team, that are
going to be there to help
when you have a question.
And then the final
thing, I think
it's really important for people
to show up around who they are
and what they have
to contribute.
You know, I've been in these
amazing tech design sessions
where we're at a whiteboard and
someone who maybe doesn't speak
up all the time
contributes something
and it shifts the conversation.
So be willing to take those
risks, to speak up, even when
you're in early stages of
your career, early stages
of building your
domain expertise.
I mean, I think one of the
great things about tech
is, we're always learning.
It's always changing.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
And so we're all--
if we have that
beginner's mindset,
we're all kind of
in the same place.
We all have imposter syndrome.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, yes we do.
MARK MANDEL: Except
for one of our friends.
MELANIE WARRICK: Except
for one who doesn't.
Yes, you're right.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: In
previous episode.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: But I
mean, I say it all the time.
Software is a team sport.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
Like, sure, you
can write software on your own.
But the fun and the
impact is so much greater
when you do it together
and you do with a team
that you have fun and you
can look to for support.
And so my advice would,
be find that team
where you're excited
about the work
that you're doing, that
you can do it together.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah,
and off of that also,
for anybody who's
considering leadership
in software and tech, any
advice for them specifically?
[LAUGHTER]
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Don't do it.
MARK MANDEL: We ask
the hard questions
here at the "GCP Podcast."
MELANIE WARRICK: Only the
ones that make people cry.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: No--
things are moving really fast.
So as a leader, we've talked,
just in this short discussion
today about continuous learning.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: You
have to do it, right?
Staying close to your
user communities.
Looking for good solutions,
because no company
is going to do it all.
So this combination
of first party,
open source,
partner integration.
And as someone
coming into the space
as a leader, sort of being
thoughtful about pulling
together the resources
to create the best
offering for the particular
problem that you're solving,
and doing that in a way
where you're building a team
that has different perspectives
and different areas
of expertise to contribute
to that problem.
So I think being really
open is an important part
of leadership, being curious,
and then investing in people
to build a team, because
your job as a leader
is really to serve your team
and to provide direction
and guidance and support.
And so really embracing
that, I think,
is key to being a
successful leader.
MARK MANDEL: You were
talking a little bit
about an empathy, as well,
in the general sense.
Do you feel that also has a deep
impact as well in leadership
skills?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: It does.
Understanding what
motivates people
and what people care about
and what they're connected to,
understanding people are
going through all sorts
of things outside of work.
And I think there's
a real opportunity
to come from a place of
understanding and empathy,
as you said, with what's going
to help people be their best
self when they show up at work.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
I think we're pretty
much at time, but Melody,
is there anything
else we haven't
covered that you wanted to
touch on before we let you go?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: No.
I want to say thank you.
I love the podcast.
I'm just going to
keep following it.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you for coming.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank
you for coming on.
We're so glad-- we're
really, really glad
that you were able to
come back and join us
a second time this year.
So thank you very much
for that, and helping
us wrap this up, too.
Thank you, Melody, for coming
on the podcast with us.
I know we were really
grateful to get time again
with you this year.
I think you were our only guest
that we've had twice this year,
so that-- thank you so much.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, indeed.
MELANIE WARRICK: Mark,
that's our last interview
for the year.
MARK MANDEL: It is our last
interview for the year.
So next one, we're going to do
a wrap up episode like usual.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: But this is--
MELANIE WARRICK: This
is almost done for 2018.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: It is 2018.
[BING]
MARK MANDEL: It is 2018, indeed.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Anyways, all right.
So question of the
week, if I want
to configure third-party
notifications such as Slack
or GitHub into my Cloud
Build configuration,
how can I do that?
MARK MANDEL: Excellent question.
So Cloud Build's really nice.
So Cloud Build is a continuous
integration deployment platform
that we have at Google Cloud.
It's quite flexible
in that what it
does when it starts
things and ends things,
et cetera, et cetera,
is it pushes everything
to a Cloud Pub/Sub topic.
And then you can listen into
this Cloud Pub/Sub topic
notifications.
So when it sends data to a
topic called Cloud Builds,
you can notify on a
variety of things.
And one of the easiest
ways of doing it
is actually just
using Cloud Functions.
So you can hook a Cloud Function
into a Pub/Sub notification
and then act upon it.
So there's actually
an example we're
going to link to in the show
notes of setting up integration
with Slack, but you can do
anything with it, essentially.
So if there's an
external web hook,
so you might want to
send stuff to GitHub,
maybe you want to send stuff
to something like SendGrid
or Mailgun or a variety
of other things in there,
so from email notifications
to all sorts of other stuff,
or just making
interesting things
happen inside your
system, you can do that.
So, yeah, Cloud
Functions is a great way
to test this stuff out and
get a nice little easy way
of building it.
One other cool thing
I like about this,
too, is if you
really want to, you
can do it all in Cloud Shell.
Because it's JavaScript,
it's not hugely complicated,
you're usually only
building one function.
So I actually do that myself.
I just set up a little source
repository with my functions
in it and then I just
use the inbuilt editor
with Cloud Shell,
and it's actually
pretty nice little workflow.
MELANIE WARRICK: When you've
been talking about Cloud
Functions, you know what's
been coming into my mind,
is duct tape.
[DUCT TAPE RIPPING SOUND]
I feel like Cloud Functions is
the equivalent of duct tape.
MARK MANDEL: I think so too.
MELANIE WARRICK:
In the tech world.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: I agree.
MELANIE WARRICK: It could
have been called duct tape
or maybe that should be our--
what is it?
SPEAKER: Tag line, a
short phrase associated
with a product or service.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK: OK.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
All right, well, I know
you're getting on a plane
soon, Melanie.
Where are you off to?
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, I am off
to the extremely warm Montreal.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: All I've ever
done is complain about my time
in Montreal last December
and how cold it was.
Lovely city, lovely
people, don't get me wrong.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, yes.
MARK MANDEL: It was freezing.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: And yet
you're like, yep, December,
definitely going to Montreal.
MELANIE WARRICK: December
seems to be the month
everybody goes to Montreal.
So yeah, I'm going out
for a specific conference
and multiple workshops
that are playing out.
So I will be at Black in
AI, Latinx, Queer in AI,
and NeurIPS all this week.
And if you're there,
please come and say hi.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
I will be at KubeCon next week.
I'll be speaking
about Agones and it
looks like I'll probably also
be doing mentoring sessions
on Wednesday.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
MARK MANDEL: So if
you want to talk
about extending Kubernetes,
CRDs, [INAUDIBLE]
machinery type stuff, building
operators, any of that stuff,
would love to chat with you.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Anything else for this month?
MARK MANDEL: Sleep.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Get
back over jet lag.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's
a smart way to go.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I
think that'll do it.
MELANIE WARRICK:
All right, Mark,
I think that's it
for us this week.
MARK MANDEL: Well,
Melanie, thank you
for joining me for yet
another week on the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]